hey what can I get you our house coffee
is four hours old and I just had a panic
attack in our walk-in freezer it's all
you didn't use the tip jar so I'm gonna
grab your muffin with my bare hands
this milk expired two days ago but if I
add some chocolate you really won't
notice the difference
oh I'm laughing to cover up how badly I
just burned myself which coffee is my
favorite well the single origin is nice
and fruity and the house blend tastes
like a chemical fire oh you didn't
actually say you wanted ice but that's
no problem I'll just remake it and put
my fingers in it a flavored latte is
pretty much just a milkshake and if you
get whipped cream on it
it's a milkshake I'm only smiling
because my face muscles are so full of
caffeine that if I relax them my heart
might explode oh thanks is our coffee
strong well I haven't slept for days and
I feel like I'm in a waking nightmare
I actually really like waking up early
for this job lets me get off work at
2:00 p.m. so I can immediately start day
drinking quadruple latte with
half-and-half
enjoy your pad you seem like an [ __ ]
so I'm gonna give you the smallest
croissant it's the one thing in my life
that I can control I want that
cappuccino extra hot it's gonna burn
your face off one cup of sugar syrup for
pulse
you know I serve you every morning but
if I see in public I'm gonna run the
opposite direction how am i doing
I'm hoping the replaces hangover with
enough coffee to jumpstart a dump truck
thanks for ordering tea it's something
you probably should have made at home
this isn't what you ordered but I'm
gonna call your name anyway cuz I really
don't
you